hey Vsauce Michael here when you call
customer service and here this to ensure
quality service your call may be
monitored or recorded they're not
kidding over the last year the marchek's
Institute analyzed more than 600,000
recorded phone conversations Americans
made to businesses in the United States
turns out people from Ohio were the most
likely to use curse words the a word the
F word and the S word Washington State
residents were the least likely to use
bad words but what makes a word bad will
be careful because etymologically
speaking even the word bad can be
considered a bad word
it began in Old English as a derogatory
term for an effeminate man 80% of swear
words overheard in public in 1986 1997
and 2006 were essentially the same
one-third of all counts included the top
two the F word and the S word slates
brilliant lexicon valley podcast
reported that these 10 words make up
about 0.7 percent of the average English
speakers daily vocabulary which means
socially unacceptable words are used
almost as often as socially descriptive
words first-person plural pronouns
account for about 1 percent of the words
we say every day when a bad word is
bleeped it is covered with a 1 kilohertz
sine wave which sounds like this son of
a by the way the symbols and squiggles
that are used to represent a bad word
have a name they're called growl exceeds
they were named by Mort Walker in his
seminal the lexicon of comic onna he
names a lot of things but most of them
show stuff they don't hide stuff why the
need to hide bad words especially if we
all pretty much know what's being said
well there is no one single reason bad
words are bad steven pinker in his
excellent lecture on the topic delineate
five types of swearing first of all some
words are bad on purpose they are
created and/or used with the intent to
hurt others he calls this abusive
swearing
using words to insult humiliate
objectify or marginalized disfavored
people now if that disfavored person is
God we're talking about Supernatural
sweater which was particularly taboo in
Victorian times it was believed that
casually or vainly referring to God
would physically injure God himself
literally so at the time people were
forced to come up with euphemisms like
shouts and gadzooks which originally
meant God's wounds and gods hooks
referring to the nails driven through
the hands of Jesus historically swear
words often came from things we were
afraid of things we perceived as
dangerous stronger than us and mercurial
such as death disease and infirmity sex
and sexually transmitted diseases as
well as body fluids germy gross the flu
via words for those gross things became
gross and bad in and of themselves
uncouth to speak
but not all words for gross things are
socially unacceptable which brings us to
Pinker's second type of swearing
emphatic sweary em fat expiring is where
the tab unas of bad words becomes quite
practical you wouldn't usually use those
words but when you really want to convey
that your current emotions matter more
to you than proper social conduct
you can use them dysphemism a euphemism
is a kind acceptable word that allows
you to talk about something unpleasant
while simultaneously letting everyone
know you totally get that it's
unpleasant and want to respect that for
instance if you want to be professional
you wouldn't say you might say defecate
if on the other hand you really want to
drive home just how unpleasant the
experience was this some isms can help
out a lot it wasn't a bag of canine
defecation you found on your front porch
it was a bag of hot dogs both of these
words refer to pretty much the same
thing but they have different levels of
social acceptability and that's very
helpful it means word choice allows us
to not only refer to things in the real
world but also to how we feel about them
if both of these words had the same
level of social acceptance we might even
have to find new batter words so as not
to lose the power language currently has
to express emotion
Polson discussed but when it comes to
two words referring to the same thing
but with different levels of social
acceptance who decides which one's good
and which one's bad well historically
many of the bad words we use today are
the result of class differences in
medieval England the lower-class
Saxons spoke a Germanic tongue while the
upper-class Normans spoke a language
related to French and Latin English as
we know it today contains many
consequences of their differences the
lower-class worked with animals and from
them we get animal names the upper-class
only ate the animals which is where the
names of the meat come from today's
swear words are similar defecation stems
from fancy-pants Latin whereas the less
classy is Germanic there's also
idiomatic swearing where nothing is
being emphasized no dysphemism is meant
instead it's an easygoing type of
swearing that shows an atmosphere is
casual bad words can be used we're all
close here it's okay to swear we're all
cool cathartic swearing is a bit
different it gives us lalu Kezia the
medical term for the relief swearing
provides when you're in pain in the
brain
swearing seems to involve different
regions than regular language which may
explain why people with aphasia caused
by brain damage struggle to comprehend
or construct spoken words but yet are
fluent at swearing or why people with
coprolalia control normal language just
fine but involuntarily utter profanity
and obscene words it turns out swearing
may be centralized in the limbic system
along with emotions many
animals make automatic noises with in
pain or threatened to startle or
intimidate attackers or to let others
know what's going on humans bad words
are great for this purpose that hurt a
bonus makes them special people wouldn't
use them otherwise so they are great
alarms swearing is changing some bad
words are being used more and more
frequently of the seven words George
Carlin said you could never say on
television today every second 22 of them
are sent out on Twitter so what will
swearing look like in the future it
probably won't go away altogether it's
too useful but the words we don't like
will likely change history has shown
that as disease becomes less scary and
sex and the supernatural more personal
words related to them become less taboo
and more common
whereas words that were common in the
past are increasingly unpleasant perhaps
in the future spurt not by runaway
political correctness but by wider
knowledge words like schizo mental ASPI
or even depressed we'll take the swear
stage or as John McWhorter ventured
words centered around class and the gap
between opportunity and disadvantage
will become more taboo salt-of-the-earth
trash Chow [ __ ] urban as a pejorative
when Mackay hatch started a no cussing
Club at his school his campaign became
the target of so many online jokes and
insults for being lame or anti free
speech on his book he literally
subtitled his own name the most cyber
bullied kid
in the world people care about this
stuff is it censorship to tell us what
we can and cannot say or is it a safety
seal ensuring certain dysphemism don't
get worn down to a quotidian bluntness
like every other word or is the badness
of bad words a boundary a moving
boundary of what we reject sometimes
arbitrary sometimes irrational but
always moving in the direction of
acceptance moving forward crime and
inequality have existed ever since they
could but when NWA released a reaction
in the form of a song with a bad word in
the title the police the Federal Bureau
of Investigations released a statement
against the song it was the only time up
until then and since the FBI has ever
issued an official statement about a
work of art bad words have power if you
want to push for change you'll need
something to push if everything's fine
nothing's cool so bad words are the
precipitate of a larger reaction the
process of us slowly becoming what we
want to become
that's some deep and as always thanks
for watching
[Music]